welcome to PFT Ooty on Yahoo Sports
Peter King Mike Florio talking about
important issues throughout the National
Football League and here's an important
issue because this is a franchise that
saw its Super Bowl win total leapfrogged
earlier this year by the New England
Patriots is now the Patriots with six
the Steelers with six and the 49ers
stuck on five since 1994
are these San Francisco 49ers Peter a
legitimate threat to win the Superbowl
I'd say they're a serious contender Mike
and one of the things would that I look
at right now in the NFC which clearly
doesn't have you know does not have from
top to bottom a bunch of flawless teams
but if you look at the teams that look
like the three best teams after five
weeks you look at San Francisco the only
undefeated team left you look at New
Orleans and you look at Green Bay and
what do they all have in common
resurgent defenses that can play games
in the teens and win them if need be and
that's where they separate themselves
from the pack all of them obviously have
good offenses and all of them have
top-ten defenses in the NFL and I think
that is what it takes the balance the
consistency to have a chance to win
multiple games in January well that's
the key it's one thing to get to the
playoffs but if you want to win playoff
games when it's single elimination you
need to have balance and you need to
have the running game which the 49ers
have but you need to have the defense to
go along with it and I was saying
yesterday that the Packers are the most
balanced team in the NFC but after
watching that game last night and seeing
what the 49ers did to the Browns I've
got to reconsider it I've got to revisit
it and I really do believe that the
49ers have potentially something special
going on here now look it could all come
crashing down if they lose to the Rams
on Sunday and the Rams have extra time
to get ready and the 49ers are operating
on a short week and that could end up
being a great great game and
a hell of an opportunity for the 49ers
to deliver a knockout blow at least as
the division title is concerned to the
Rams who would fall to 3 & 3 but I think
the 49ers are going to soon emerge as
everyone's darling so far they're still
kind of on that fringe but I think
people are gonna realize that they do
have a legitimate shot and people are
gonna be fascinated Peter by the
possibility of Tom Brady finally playing
a Superbowl game against the team that
he grew up rooting for against the
quarterback who was traded out of New
England I'll tell you what I would have
a lot of fun talking about 49ers
Patriots for two weeks in advance of
Super Bowl 54 it would be great and and
Mike I would I would just say this
I mean you raised two points number one
about the Rams game this week the Rams
are gonna realize in essence this is the
most important game of their season and
and I won't
I won't think that II love the 49ers
unless it's 42 three Rams and which I
don't think it'll be so I mean this game
is a lot more important for the Rams and
it is for the 49ers it's in LA I think
mcveigh's gonna have them ready yeah and
look I don't know when but but I'll say
that and the other thing I'll say is
that you know every spring I put I rank
the team's 1 to 32 and this past spring
when I ranked the team's 1 to 32
I put the 49ers 7th and I basically said
that hey look I think this is a playoff
team unless Jimmy Garoppolo gets hurt
again and and obviously I stick to that
but the outcry of you know you are an
imbecile was hot was was bigger on that
both in emails and tweets and everything
on that and my single response was was
only this do you think as you watch NFL
history that NFL history in 2018 and the
standings in 2018 are going to be the
same as they were in 2019 do you learn
nothing from history from watching this
game and so I just I like the 40
niners then and obviously they have
reinforced that in the last two months
yeah every year is a different story in
the NFL for every team except the
Patriots who seem to be in the final
four or in the final two or that for no
one's every single year we'll see you
all next time here PFT ot on Yahoo
Sports
[Music]
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports